you have stayed friends with elton i
have yeah it's still quite i mean you
know i've known him for quite a few
years now but it's still and i mean it
must be weird for him that people i
still go when he calls and he goes hello
and you go
[ __ ] hell you know
i mean you you're friends with alton too
you you but no but it's still
it is weird isn't it you you just can't
get used to it and yeah and he does a
really lovely job i mean aside from the
fact he's always dripping in glitter and
gold he does a good he does a good job
of kind of you know leveling the playing
field but hasn't he given you a lovely
name a nickname yeah i am i do have that
honor i think like in the 70s it was a
bit of a thing that that he did as he
gave his friends
drag names and i i did get one
in about 20
18 2019 and as i said to you earlier i i
have a campervan and elton thought that
was really really funny um and i'm welsh
and so he he he called me blood
bloodwind campervan
he still signs emails dear blodwyn
where the [ __ ] are you you haven't
picked up the phone
i love that
campervan
yeah
[Music]